a long time senior official laid off by
one of Wall Street's top financial firms
is now suing accusing the company of
racial bias against black women Marilyn
Booker spent more than a quarter-century
at Morgan Stanley
she once led the firm's diversity and
inclusion program and now she claims in
her words that black lives do not matter
at Morgan Stanley now the firm strongly
disputes that national correspondent
Jericka Duncan spoke with Booker in her
first Network TV interview since filing
the lawsuit dareka Marilyn Booker has a
lot to say good morning to you good
morning Marilyn Booker used to work
right here at the headquarters and she
says listen she was an advocate for
black employees in fact in recent years
she had been pushing a program that
would allow for adequate training and
support for black financial managers so
that they could advance within the
company but Booker says she believes
those after and other things caused
Morgan Stanley to eliminate her position
Marilyn Booker recalled the day she
learned her 26-year career at Morgan
Stanley was over the Human Resources
person told me that my job was being
eliminated and the way they did it 26
years loyal employee I like to say that
I bled Morgan Stanley blue and they
fired me like I was a temp that was on
December 9th 2019 jobs are on the
chopping block at Morgan Stanley amid a
round of layoffs that Morgan Stanley
said included around 1,500 employees
more than 100 of which were managing
directors like Booker for 16 years
Booker served as the global head of
diversity I remember when I was in that
role the firm with respect to black
employees it was eight point eight
percent the last ten years under James
Gorman that number is now five point
eight percent what about you mr. Gorman
James Gorman took over as CEO in 2010
around the same time Booker was moved to
the wealth management division morgan
stanley disputes Booker's claim and says
the overall number of black employees
that the company has increased in the
last decade going from four point six
percent to five point eight percent and
number of black managing directors has
more than tripled but Booker says the
problem with diversity goes beyond
numbers they do not get the same
mentoring they don't get the same
support so they either fail out of the
program or they walk away in defeat
within months of proposing an idea to
address those problems Booker says she
was fired and this month she filed a
lawsuit bringing claims against Gorman
and managing director Barry Crouch for
race and gender discrimination
retaliation and unequal pay Booker's
attorney Jean Christensen I believe we
will be able to show that women at
Morgan Stanley in various positions are
underpaid compared to their male peers
but black female employees specifically
are discriminated against even worse why
do you think that is companies like
Morgan Stanley have been getting away
with this for years doing the right
thing alone isn't compelling enough for
most companies
Martin Davidson has been advising major
banks on diversity programs for over 15
years I have a hard time thinking about
anyone that has not dealt with this with
you sometimes dealing with these
lawsuits and settling them for what
seemed like large amounts of money for
them is just a cost of doing business
just one week after protests erupted
over the death of George Floyd Morgan
Stanley CEO sent an email to staff
acknowledging a turning point in race
relations and announcing 25 million
dollars to create an institute of
inclusion I wonder if this tragic thing
had not happened with George Floyd if
all of these epiphanies would have taken
place what outcome are you hoping for I
am hopeful that CEOs will take a look at
my case and then take a critical look at
their organizations
and ask themselves is writing a check to
the n-double-a-cp LDF enough is forming
a committee enough I want them to give
people the freedom to speak freely about
what the issues are and lastly I want
them to give black people a safe space
to be able to do that before they get to
the point where they have to either
leave the organization or they end up in
court with the organization Morgan's
family tells CBS this morning that it
strongly rejects the allegations in the
lawsuit of discrimination and unequal
pay the company emphasized that its new
inclusion Institute is just one of many
pieces of a broader and long-running
standing to try and address diversity in
fact they said they have 30 employees
that are dedicated to tackling those
specific issues but Booker's attorney
meanwhile said that since filing that
lawsuit she's received more than 10
calls from current and former employees
with similar complaints as Booker Tony
boy the whole thing calls to mind
Mellody Hobson suggestion that if you
want to change diversity numbers in
corporate America you've got to tie them
to executive pay money talks there and
elsewhere shreeka thank you very much